good morning John language is extremely
bizarre if I didn't know about languages
and you tried to explain language to me
I don't know that I'd believe you a set
of sounds that allows two animals to
communicate just a tremendous amount of
information over a very short period of
Time how do the sounds work well
sometimes like a single sound is one
idea like if I say eh then you know what
that means but mostly you take a bunch
of sounds and you mash them up together
into one thing and that has a meaning
and that's a word and then you take a
bunch of those mased up groups of sounds
and you mash them up more and then you
make a sentence and that can have like a
whole thought in it like imagine one
animal is
like and then another one
replies and then you fall in love and
then if people do that enough over
100,000 years or so they like cure
cancers and make the iPhone and take
over the whole planet the dry Parts
anyway most of the wet parts are not
ours yet let's leave it that way now
another thing if you did get the idea of
language across to me a person who'd
never heard about language before I
would not expect that if you separate
two groups of people for not very long
at the end of that process they will not
be able to understand each other anymore
but that does happen language is
constantly shifting and evolving and
over enough time language is completely
separate from each other and that is the
cause of both unquestionable
extraordinary beauty and diversity and
it's also one of the greatest barriers
to human cross-cultural empathy and it's
also why in France there are some
newscasters talking about jobs being
taken by cat I farted Phil fish on
Mastadon says life is now extra surreal
for French speakers right now because in
French phonetically chat GPT sounds
exactly like cat I farted sh everywhere
on TV in the news people going cat I
farted over and over with a straight
face is catti farted going to steal your
job How are schools dealing with catti
farted lawyer caught using catti farted
it's incredible but I asked people on
Twitter and French people reported that
when they're talking about chat like the
internet thing of a chat they tend to
say chat that doesn't break the fun
though instead of catti farted it's
chatti farted I actually asked chat I
farted if it knew about this yes I've
heard that before when pronounced in Fr
chat GPT can sound humorously like
chat nine which translates to cat I
farted it's a funny coincidence in the
way different languages can make certain
phrases sound and then since I knew
there were I asked chat GPT if there
were any other examples of similar
situations yes there have been several
instances the Chevrolet Nova this is a
classic example in Spanish Nova means
doesn't go however this story is more of
an urban legend the Nova actually sold
well in Spanish-speaking countries Pepsi
in China Pepsi's slogan Pepsi brings you
back to life was initially translated as
network error still some glitches to
work out I did my own research here and
it turns out it translates to Pepsi
brings your ancestors back from the
grave which not great but also not
really what I meant I want like brand
names that had to be changed and there
are actually a lot of examples of those
in this might be the part of the video
where anybody under the age of maybe 13
should stop watching the Norwegian
cheese brand cavy needed a name change
in Greece as that's a particularly
vulgar term for penis and while the
Chevrolet Nova turned out to be a fine
name in Spanish speaking markets the
Mazda lauta was not Herber baby food
needed a name change in France as well
since that in French means vomit Ikea
made a bit of a mistake with a bunk bed
called the gvic which uh in German G is
obviously good I'll let you guess what
Vic is which also became a problem for
Vicks a us company that sells cold
medicines Sega in Italian is also a
sexual act though one that is more often
done alone Sega and look English is not
alone they did decide to go on ahead
with the Nintendo Wii and honestly they
pulled it off you could make a very long
video just of examples of stuff like
this and it's interesting the ones that
turn out to be problems don't tend to be
like fun little mistakes they tend to be
true vulgarity and no one would say that
saying cat I farted is true vulgarity
but despite that it seems like a lot of
people in France are solving this
problem by instead of saying chat jeete
or chat je they're just saying it
phonetically in English they're saying
Chad GPT which honestly France do not
let us down here I know you love your
language stick with it do the brave
thing please call the most revolutionary
language tool of this Century cat I
farted please I believe in you we need
this John I'll see you on Tuesday